les beaux ils ont un sens certain
vous savez tout ça c'est un exemple un
petit peu stupide mais ce soir angers
vous avez pas demander à quelqu'un passe
moi le poulet puissent manger l'assiette
non je le dis c'est un exemple subtil
mais aussi perler culturelle soit il
cet exemple est aussi réel sur des
notions plus complexe et on en parle
ensemble parce que c'était à moi vous
avez dû l'entendre ses droits aient pu
éventuellement le droit international de
l'environnement
oui mais cette bataille des mots elle
n'existe pas uniquement en matière
environnementale
vous avez dû en entendre parler du jour
est ce que l'état islamique ennahda est
ce que c'est un terroriste comment
définir un terroriste est ce que c'est
un dictateur etc etc bref rien de
nouveau ce soir c'est quelque chose de
gaulle mais bien évidemment c'est une
soirée relative à l'environnement et
nous allons parler de tensions quatre
fonctions que l'on donné ces îles sont
extrêmement utiles ise mais assez mal
comprises hors mal interprété mais
diapositives seront très austère il n'y
aura que des mots cet expert je ne veux
pas vous influencer en quoi ce soit sur
la compréhension des notions que je vais
présenter donc la notion et le
réchauffement climatique
oui il dit maman n'ont pu parler du
réchauffement climatique en 2015 elle
personnel oui évidemment j'ai cette
notion le grand public les hommes
politiques
nos élus ch et les scientifiques alors
messieurs les scientifiques eux les
verts de côté parce qu ils utilisent de
la meilleure manière possible et je vous
renvoie au dernier rapport du giec n'ont
pas d'honneur c'est plutôt l'analyse
qu'en fait le grand public de manière
donc général oui alors et le les
juristes est ce qu'on parle de
changement climatique est ce que je le
parle de réchauffement climatique
est ce que j'en ai déjà parlé dans les
haies puis
on n'utilise pas du tout cette
expression pourquoi alors que tout le
monde en parle à travers ce qu'on passe
sur des textes juridiques et aux textes
juridiques relatifs à cette notion c'est
la convention cadre des nations unies 92
sur les changements climatiques et non
pas le réchauffement utiliser le terme
de changement et non pas de choses 3,92
tout le monde a commencé à parler d'
sainte dans les années 2000 eh bien ça
n'a pas été choisi au hasard parce que
c'est un terme beaucoup plus de temps
que celui de réchauffement qui peut
critiquer la notion d'évolution du
climat
le climat change il pleut et vos
graphiques et que ça évidemment
quasiment personne en bref c'est une
option très très neutre ok on à la
notion de réchauffement climatique qui
fait référence à une définition
scientifique précise définition précise
mais on a utilisé à tort et à travers
peut-être un peu trop outrancière cette
notion est elle a été mal compris mal
interprétés je représente le saint avé
super toile et les salaires oui et il
m'est arrivé d'entendre à des personnes
dire qu est ce qu il a fait froid cette
année c'est n'importe quoi ce soir dans
la chambre consultative perdant le
climat qui se réchauffe pas du tout oui
ça paraît en grâce du pid et caricatural
mais c'est une réalité
l'utilisation peut être à répétition de
ce terme
après angers regret une génération de
personnes qui pensent que c'est une
lubie de chercheurs voire le cdh un
complot mondial
un petit peu loin dans l'analyse et vous
serez tenté de me dire et alors qu'est
ce que ça change
et bien cette analyse du terme de
réchauffement climatique a pu provoquer
des ralentissements au niveau du rôle
international
on y reviendra un petit peu plus tard un
deuxième motion et vous connaissez tous
aussi celle de réfugiés climatiques
et ça c'est un réfugié climatique
endroit alors
l'aide internationale le réfugié
climatique c'est absolument rien ça
n'existe pas cette notion dans toutes en
panne n'a aucune existence juridique
absolue c'est bien vous parlez de choses
qui se bat - comté qu'est ce que c'est
un réfugié
et bien si on se base sur la convention
de genève de 1951 un réfugié
c'est une personne qui fuit son état
pour des raisons de persécution dans et
nick religieuses politiques russes de
guerre et y trouve dans le jaune dans un
autre état ce relativement simple et la
situation concrète en 2015 et notamment
ses premières en club et 15 quelle est
la situation aujourd'hui les médias bien
vendu on a des personnes qui fuient la
syrie qui figure à cause de la guerre et
qui essaye de trouver refuge en e3 est à
ecône elles prennent pour des lignes en
les appels migrants et non pas réfugié
c'est plutôt intéressant maintenant dans
notre région le pacifique des personnes
et aussi parfois
puis les dérèglements climatiques pour
prouver un produit jugé entièrement dans
le président commence on les appelle les
réfugiés donc d'un côté on appelle à des
personnes qui pourraient prétendre au
statut de réfugié et deux ans la belle
les réfugiés à la des personnes qui
n'ont aucun statut juridique existant
est la conséquence de cette utilisation
des mots la conséquence elle est
extrêmement sain au final nous ça soit
en europe ou d'un massif iq et la
hongrie les deux protections ces
personnes particulièrement vulnérables
oui que ce soit les réfugiés donc en
syrie en irak où les personnes fuyant
les dérèglements climatiques
oui l'utiliser un intermède qui n'existe
pas c'est en quelque sorte évacuer
tranquillement
quant à ce qui se passe en europe c'est
là aussi fermé les yeux sur un problème
bien réel
attention ça évolue quand même un petit
peu
j'entends de plus en plus le père
réfugié utilisé est encore de migrants
et réfugiés qui est beaucoup plus large
oui ça nous permet pas suivez notre
motion suivante celle de disparition
d'un tome et en anglais c'est encore
mieux
ces guignols vous imaginez un logement
dans cette seule un petit pouce donné
par est ça aussi à la dispersion et
l'horreur alors si vous connaissez des
gens en 2010 ironise apple ne vend pas
il ne se transforme en atlantique
il aurait à faire face un bien d'autres
problèmes
j'avais même où il est c'est la grosse
difficulté à une utilisation à
répétition se perdre ses concerts
organisés sur une seule chose au final
la gueule vous savez tous c'est la
montée du niveau de la mer comment
s'organise sur la montée du niveau de la
mer alors qu'il existe d'autres
problématiques liées au changement
climatique salinisation des eaux et ont
dû prononcer cyclo détente et qui sont
éventuellement plus intense en ce moment
avec la ligne hop etc
je suis pas scientifique mais patience
dieu est la conséquence au niveau
juridique au niveau juridique aussi on
oublie certaines choses
qu'est ce que c'est une ville selon la
convention mon pédalier 82 1e c'est un
espace qui a mauvais goût est totalement
découvert ok donc si à marée haute
y compris des marionnettes lui n'est pas
totalement découverte
on peut la considérer comme étant un
rocher est un objet réel problème
et bien il ne peut servir de base aux
zones un espace maritime
je parle bien évidemment de la nba
dieu zone économique exclusive adieu
ressources 1 c'est là ont doublé en
lumière berck par la totalisation sur un
seul terme
on en vient à oublier autre problème et
est bien présent contre partie de la
problématique liée à l'utilisation
outrancière de se perdre
savané aussi mais on peut compter une
certaine panique qui va pousser à des
migrations a la cote en ce moment je dis
pas que c'est mal de ce fait de prévenir
bien évidemment alors que bien
évidemment pour l'instant coupable m
oui n'oubliez pas le droit international
le but c'est de préserver les
territoires pal poussé à l'aise parce
que la dernière notion celle de son côté
abou merhi au 21
on va parler tu mènes lui sur la petit
que de présentation keynote ellipses on
voit simplement à cause de la côte 21 et
visuel encore en cours de mandat mais
évidemment ça correspond à quoi parce
que je plante à goody est de 21 je
recycle des gsop à terre oui mais à quoi
cela correspond ce prêt simple coque
c'est la concurrence à une réunion des
épargnants ratifié la convention rendu
prévention la convention qui atteint
démission du changement climatique
21 c'est la vendée vienne fois qu'il se
réalise
allawi se réunissent une fois par an
mais la convention entre en vigueur
94 c'est la première réunion a eu lieu
en 95 même si je suis nul en maths et en
allemand c'est bon là on doit y aller
non c'est justement pourquoi son bassine
avec pour 21,6 ils sont en lice chaque
année l'année dernière c'était au pérou
l'année prochaine ce sera malheur et ont
mis la différence cet avis est bien la
différence c'est bon d'avoir gagné ici
parvenir à un accord
embrayant et universiades sur la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre ok en
fait c'est déjà c'est ce qu'on appelle
de kyoto qui l'a de 97
mais le propos des deux bourgs et l'a
pas vraiment sociaux n'a pas fait n'a
jamais fait l'unanimité
en bref on essaye de me passer la suite
est de construire un traité un véritable
traité sur des fondements solides
est ce que c'est important de 21 oui la
conférence de paris en décembre et créer
créer importante à ce niveau là et je
vous conseille de nous informer à ce
propos parce que en la basilique
donc on est quand même dans une région
particulièrement vulnérable à forcer les
changements climatiques et pour conclure
plaisir vous pouvez y est reproché
d'être un oeil en quoi l'utilisation de
mots plus adéquat changerait quoi que ce
soit pour l'international
pourquoi utiliser tel point par rapport
à un autre
changer quelque chose est-ce que ça va
me changer quelque chose c'est bien le
monde des troubles est ce que ça mais
attention ne soyez pas dupes
au plan international les mots ont une
importance fondamentale
si vous avez suivi c'est la 66e
assemblée générale des nations-unies en
ce moment et récemment conclu on peut en
conclure que en fonctionnement utilisé
est bien plus pauvres et mobiliser
copan au niveau du droit international
ou au contraire à les actions concrètes
le mot de la fin ne mangez pas mes
services